[Musique]
fais
tu sais que j'aime ce jeu
en y jouant, ce n'est pas juste pour le plaisir
cette fois
et donc je suis là et je
resterai
et je te laisserai tracer la ligne
tu sais que j'aime ce jeu
nous jouons à manger juste pour un
moment de kickstarter
et donc je suis là
et je vais rester
[Musique]
j'espère que tu le ressens aussi dis-moi tout ce que je
t'appartiens tu m'appartiens
aussi fille tu dois savoir
ça  Je n'irai jamais
juste donne-moi les règles quand d'une manière ou d'une autre
bébé tu sais que
j'aime ce jeu auquel nous jouons, ce
n'est pas juste pour le temps de Kix
[Musique]
et donc je suis là
et je vais rester
ok tu
sais que j'adore ce jeu auquel nous jouons en
mangeant juste pour tes enfants cette fois
et donc
[Musique]
alors s'il te plaît, vas-y doucement, je vais y jouer
correctement,
je dois te faire savoir bébé
que je t'aime
si tu peux garder ça
affrontez notre seigneur, vous savez que nous allons le
faire fonctionner d'une manière ou d'une autre,
comment vous savez que j'aime
ce jeu tout en y jouant, ce
n'est pas seulement pour le temps de Kickstarter
et donc je suis ici
en haut oh je vais
rester hé
[Musique]
toi
[  Musique]
et comment je vais rester
[Musique]
tu sais que j'aime ce jeu
en jouant à
[Musique]
tu sais que j'aime ce jeu